règle générale chaque produit en
épicerie doit présenter sur son
emballage un tableau de la valeur
nutritive
d'abord quand on regarde un tableau on à
la portion qui est indiquée pour
laquelle on calcule la valeur nutritive
donc on va voir les calories et la
valeur pour 12 nutriments et à droite on
est ce qu'on appelle pourcentage de la
valeur quotidienne qui viennent nous
dire rapidement c'est l'aliment
conseille beaucoup ou pour beaucoup
d'éléments en question les fabricants
utilisent deux méthodes reconnues par le
gouvernement pour déterminer la valeur
nutritive affichés sur les emballages
la nutritionniste carole fournier dirige
une entreprise qui fournit à l'industrie
agroalimentaire les tableaux pour leurs
différents produits soient qui font
analyser le produit en laboratoire et
plust une décomposition du produit avec
des procédés chimiques aux vieilles
analyse par base de données ces bases de
données proviennent principalement du
fichier canadien sur les éléments
nutritifs de santé canada ou du usd food
datacenters des états unis nous en plus
on va vérifier les valeurs raison du
sang selon les met dans la base de
données voici notre tableau de valeur
nutritive à portion avec les valeurs
arrondi l'agencé canadienne d'inspection
des aliments tolère une certaine marge
d'erreur sur ces valeurs
puis ceux moins 20 pour ça ça semble
beaucoup mais on travaille avec des
aliments qui change beaucoup
une tomate cultivée en juillet pin
tomates du mois de janvier massa
peut-être pas la même valeur nutritive
dans son plus récent ouvrage la jungle
alimentaire la nutritionniste julie
desgroseilliers se penche sur la façon
de bien se servir du tableau
d'abord la portion et ça c'est important
de regarder la portion parce que si on
veut comparer avec d'autres produits
on veut comparer à quantité égale est ce
intéressant aussi si on surveille ses
apports en nutriments précis par exemple
en cercle
julie considère que la qualité d'un
produit ne repose aucunement sur la
teneur en calories qu'il contient c'est
mieux de choisir un produit qui est un
peu plus calorique qui vont me fournit
des protéines des fibres des bons gras
versus un aliment qui allégé - calories
mais bourrés d'additifs de colorants
d'agents de conservation
ensuite les lipides baisser la quantité
totale de matière grasse que mon produit
vont me fournis en matière de lipides le
message à retenir c'est que c'est mieux
de miser sur la qualité que sur la
quantité
et qu'est ce que la qualité c'est ce
qu'on appelle les gras mono et poly
insaturés
alors si je prends mon totale de matière
grasse et que je soustrais les mauvais
gras saturés et trans
ça me donne la quantité de bons gros
ensuite qu'on a le cholestérol
contrairement à la croyance populaire le
cholestérol qu'on trouve dans les
aliments ont pour beaucoup d'impact sur
le cholestérol sanguin c'est davantage
les gros saturés et trans qui font
augmenter le cholestérol sanguin
ensuite le sodium on sait tous que trop
de sodium peut faire augmenter la
pression artérielle qui est un facteur
de risque important des maladies du
coeur
ensuite les glucides c'est le total des
fibres des sucres et des amis dont on a
besoin glucides c'est le carburant par
excellence pour toutes les cellules de
notre corps humain notamment pour le
cerveau si plutôt le sucre qu'on
avantage à regarder plus attentivement
ensuite les protéines les protéines vous
remarqué que pas de pourcentage à la
valeur quotidienne sont une alimentation
variée équilibrée batoul et tous les
canadiens vont combler leurs besoins en
protéines pour bien comprendre la valeur
nutritive d'un produit
c'est au pourcentage de la valeur
quotidienne que l'on devrait s'attarder
on a deux chiffres a retenu 5 et 15
un pourcentage de 5 % et - nous dit que
c'est pour beaucoup c'est une faible
teneur et 15% et plus c'est beaucoup et
entre les 2 10% c'est une teneur moyenne
alors vous aurez compris que tout ce qui
est gagnant pour la santé des fibres des
vitamines des minéraux on veut les
pourcentages les plus élevés idéalement
au delà de 15 et al'inverse tout ce qui
est ce diom gras saturés 30 on veut les
pourcentages les plus faibles idéalement
en bas de 5 pour ça donc on cherche pas
à voir ça pour ça surtout pour les
instruments qui sont moins gagnant pour
la santé on peut s'étonner que pour le
sucre il n'y ait pas de pourcentage de
la valeur quotidienne
le gouvernement fédéral a d'ailleurs
corriger cela et les fabricants ont
jusqu'en 2022 pour l'indiquer dans le
tableau et avant choisir on devrait
toujours examiner la liste des
ingrédients
en fait combiner la liste d'ingrédients
avec le tableau de la valeur nutritive
on est en business on a vraiment une
bonne idée de ce qu'on met dans l'est
pas ni comparons deux bois de gracq
l'est en apparence semblables on voit
ici que c'est du blé à gré entier de
l'huile végétale sel de mer merci
bonsoir trois ingrédients sont simples
qu'on connaît pour le second craquelins
en plus des ingrédients de base on
retrouve de nombreux additifs pour la
conservation la couleur et le goût est
ce qu il faut savoir quand on regarde
une liste d'ingrédients c'est que les
ingrédients sont énumérées en ordre
décroissant de poids alors l'ingrédient
le plus présent se retrouvant en tête de
liste est l'ingrédient en plus faible
quantité se retrouve à la fin alors
quand je vais faire des choix qui sont
ganga je vais rechercher par exemple les
grains entiers en premier alors que le
sel le sucre hibernant je veux à la fin
de la liste mais en même temps c'est pas
nous consommateurs d'être éduqués et
d'ouvrir l'oeil avant d'ouvrir la bouche
et d'avoir la curiosité de vraiment
regarder ce que l'aliment cage
[Musique]